here are a few examples where Ed's are
used fairly effectively you could see
here a banner ad but I read our images
based advertisements that often appear
in the side top or bottom section of our
website there i use pcc pay-per-click
model in which advertisers pay fee each
time a user clicks on this ad you could
see here on the verge that spotify is
actually taking quite a lot of real
estate over the top if we scroll down we
could see another ad over here and in
most cases if we continue scrolling down
to the bottom we could see another ad
just over here another example would be
there huffing Huffington Post and you
can see here another ed and another
example in Yahoo Finance will be
actually two ads one for their mobile
app and the other very prominently on
the right side